[Music]
so we have just Unearthed and discovered
a mystery regarding the mother long legs
of Skull Island from the monsterverse
there isn't just one of them but
actually three types of them that have
been seen and the question now Rises
could they either be three cars or even
three species or just add different life
stages there is even one that is almost
Titan in size but we will get back to
that after a while let's first look at
their biology and then go on to their
different
specimens so the super species biology
the mother longle is a giant arachin
species first featured in the 2017 film
Kong Skull Island and again in
subsequent monsterverse Comics these
creatures standing about 20 ft tall as
for the movie version they have l long
legs which resemble bamboo allowing them
to camouflage themselves in forests in
the bamboo Groves their faces look like
skulls with big red eyes and they have
additional pencil-like claws near their
heads in the Monarch Legacy of Monsters
TV series which will Air in November
they will be making a comeback a return
and will battle a crap likee monster a
super species which has not been
identified as of now these mother long
legs are large carnivorous spiders
skilled at hiding in bambo forest and
are considered dangerous to humans like
really dangerous as they will hunt
people and even view them as sprey items
their legs look like bamboo allowing
them to blend in and they have a unique
ability to camouflage in the dense
forest but although they also have
ventured into Eevee settlements at times
these spers use their sharp legs as
Spears to catch prey once they
immobilize their victims they inject
paralyzing Venom called the mother's
milk absorbing nutrients from the prey
and also they can can draw moisture from
the soil for rehydration if they're
thirsty which means their legs act like
secondary mouths additionally they have
a special way of capturing prey using
muscular tendrils from their underbelly
anything which is uneatable or inedible
is expelled and in some instances they
use webbing to capture and hold their
prey let's take a look at their life
cycle Monarch suggest that the mother
long legs might be a super mutated
version of a type of arachnet called the
opelon it is St that there is no male
specimen of the mother long legs them
being all female they reproduce
asexually creating clones of themselves
so every one of them is an exact copy of
the previous generation aside from
random mutations that might occur so
that brings us to the Crux of the topic
the three different types of mother long
legs that have been spotted in the movie
and Comics this tells us that these
creatures do not have different cars or
different species they are just one and
they do have a very long lifespan and a
complicated life cycle and that the
super species profile that has been
shown is inaccurate as of the current
low so let's get to discussing the three
life stages of this monstrous spider
firstly let's start with the smallest
one the juvenile so this one was seen in
the 2017 movie Skull Island and it was
the specimen that attacked the group in
the bamboo forest it was around 7 m or
23 ft in height it has a smaller head
that is rounded and skull-like as for
the top part and also has eight eyes its
abdomen is small relatively speaking but
it is filled with green leaf like
foliage that further emphasizes its
absorption and integration of bamboo DNA
into its genome the other visually
telling aspect are the bamboo legs
obviously now the next life stage is the
adult and while this is a gradual cycle
the adults are actually visually
different from the juveniles as seen in
the birth of Kong Comics firstly they
are way bigger with a few of them even
seem to be around 50 to 70 ft in height
or 15 to 21 M tall this is evidenced by
their battles and confrontation with
Kong which was stated to have grown to
around 200 ft tall at that time in 1995
anyway their bodies also have changed a
bit while juveniles have smaller abdomen
and heads the adults seem to have bigger
and more robust bodies coupled with
thicker and sturdy legs their tendrils
also shoot out and seem to appear like
tree branches so all in all they are big
in always
ways finally we have the final stage of
the mother longlegs the queen this is
the biggest specimen ever seen and was
spotted in the birth of Kong Comics
while the adults appear to be a quarter
or a third of the size of Kong the queen
long legs looks to rival Kong in his
young adult form there are a few stock
differences between it and the previous
stage the most prominent one is the head
Crest which adds more royalty to the
specimen and even seems to sprout out
horns from the back of the head
assessing the size compared to Kong the
queen would have been around 150 ft or
45 M tall its abdomen is also quite
telling it seems to have replaced the
bamboo leaves with a thick fur and this
might have happened gradually as it grew
it might also be that only one of these
will be present at a time commanding a
swarm of smaller long legs like a hiy
mine it would be the alpha of the group
after combating and pressed competitors
into submission which if you think about
it are just all copies of itself either
way let's do a short size comparison
with other Skull Island species the
juvenile mother long legs is 23 ft or 7
m tall which makes it taller than most
species that have been seen taller than
the smaller skull crawlers but lesser
than the biggest specimens of the scar
Buffalos and the spur mantises the adult
long legs however are bigger than the
scar buffalos bigger than spur mates and
even the siren jaws and the magma
Turtles the queen long legs would be
bigger than the 1973 Kong but smaller
than a 1995 young adult form it would
also be bigger than ramarak the big
skull devil and the cameleons but
smaller than the Kraken and also smaller
than kots and Kong so that's that so if
you like this video then watch this one
too and if you're more interested in
other movie Monsters content and
creatures then check out our Channel as
well we might have things that you have
not seen or thought about subscribe like
and we'll see you on on the next video
take care
fam